Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been a very happy day.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Dasa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambho Dasa
homage to the buddha the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one so uh we're going to move on uh this is called the wilderness of the heart the wilderness of the heart
So here's the Buddha now.
He's back up in Savatti, which is the capital of Kosala.
That's the northern part above the Ganges, obviously below the Himalayas.
And he's at Anathapindika's park.
Remember, I think it was a merchant who went out of his way to pay a lot of money for this ground that he covered with gold.
That's what he said.
He used to be a prince of jetters.
Bhikkhu.
that any bhikkhu who has not abandoned the five wildernesses of the heart and not severed the five shackles in the heart should come to growth increase and fulfillment in this dharma and discipline this is impossible so we have five wildernesses and five shackles to get rid of and when we talk about the dharma of course it's the
It's not one of ethics, excuse me, it's not one of morality.
Monks also are not supposed to kill other beings and etc, etc.
The difference is that monks have institutional rules and regulations.
So these have not got to be confused.
It's not some sort of huge moral dilemma whether to eat before noon or not.
It's just a rule that is kept by monastic order.
And the reason is that any group of people who live together, whether they like it or not, create rules and regulations.
Mostly they're hidden, they're covert rules.
So, you know, you don't go playing music at two o'clock in the morning if you're living with your family or with friends.
There's all little rules that nobody ever makes explicit, but they're there.
And remember that these rules that the monastics have,
came about because of naughty monks and nuns.
So what are these five wildernesses?
Here there is doubt, uncertainty, undecidedness and lack of confidence in the teacher, heaven forbid.
And thus the mind is not inclined to ardour, devotion, perseverance and striving.
Okay, so you have to have confidence in the teacher.
And the distinction between that and having a sort of blind faith is really important.
As I'm sure many of you know, we've had some really bad cases within the, in Buddhism, in the West of, you know, what can we say, definite heavy misbehavior by teachers.
You are always, as far as I remember, it's always men.
It's always to do with sex.
So one has to be careful that one doesn't sell your soul to the teacher.
One always keeps a certain distance, a certain quality of gentle, she would say, inquiry, a certain critical ability, right?
Or else you just become a slave.
And the point is in Buddhism, of course, in the Buddhist teaching, is that what the teacher is supposed to be doing is guiding you along the path.
So as you yourself are practicing, you'll know whether these instructions are any good or whether the teachings you're being given are helping you.
So that's it.
It's important that we have confidence in the teacher.
I remember when I
first worked with Buddhist teachers, but when I met Saito Ujanaka, who was the Mahasi teacher, a direct disciple of the Mahasi, there was just this feeling in me, this is the man, this is the one.
And luckily it turned out to be true.
The other thing we do with teachers, of course, is overestimate where they are, as always.
That's always a bit of a problem.
You always think the teacher's more attained than they actually are.
And I've definitely made that mistake.
So don't never guess where your teachers are.
It's not important.
It's not important because in a tradition, what they're doing is passing on the tradition.
And it's not important where they are in the scale of things, although it's always a benefit if they've experienced what they're teaching.
Then there is a lack of confidence, the same thing, but a lack of confidence in the Dharma.
So this again comes back to your actual experience.
If your meditation is actually helping you in your life, then obviously it's working.
So any doubt should be undermined by that.
And reading, when you come across passages which you don't understand or things that you doubt, like rebirth,
the existence of gods and heavenly realms and all that, then, you know, in Buddhism, it's not a belief system.
One always puts that on the back burner.
You know, there's no proof for it and there's no proof against it.
It's just the way it is.
It's the same with Nirvana.
If you're a committed scientific materialist, then Nirvana is something that you experience in this life in momentary forms or not at all.
So that's undermined by recognizing that we don't have to believe anything.
Then again, there's confidence in the training.
The Dharma, I suppose, there was meant for the actual teaching, the intellectual business.
And this is about the training itself.
So here we come across this terrible thing about lack of success.
You know, as meditators, we're always looking for some progress, you know, like where's the progress?
So remember, when we first start, there's an immediate effect.
We're lifted by the practice.
And because we're taught to look at things differently, there's a whole sequence of insights that we make when we first begin.
But then, of course, you hit the plateau and that's when the work starts.
So remember that progress is a bit of a... You have to be careful with the idea of progress.
I always think it's better to think in terms of the heart, in terms of whether we're becoming kinder, more gentle, more compassionate, et cetera.
and that's that for me is a an easier telltale and of course you can't look over over a week you can't say how much have i progressed this week because because sometimes you dip and then you've got to climb out of the hole and and and write a bit so it's basically looking over the past years even two or three years and then you realize yeah you know i have progressed
then there's uh anger and displeasure with companions in the holy life uh it can be jealousy you know somebody's sat there for three hours and not moved and you're fidgeting about wanting to get off after half an hour and there's all this jealousy comes up and envy so uh one has to one has to accept that as unnecessary
and uh obviously in a meditation retreat sometimes we get angry with people who sneeze and whatnot and sometimes it's very peculiar but uh you can suddenly find all this this aversion coming up towards somebody even though you don't even well you might have met them at the beginning of the retreat you know nothing about them but there's there's something about them that reminds you of something that you're very angry about so the one great thing about spiritual companions is that you don't have to like them
They're there as support.
And that's quite a liberation when you realize that.
You don't have to like your spiritual companions.
I don't have to like the monks I live with.
As long as they're keeping the rule and they're practicing, they are a support to me.
And that's great.
So these are the five wildernesses of the heart.
So we'll come back to them right at the end.
now then there are these five shackles my goodness so here uh abiku is not free now it keeps uh it keeps translating this word raga as lust but it's actually uh a sort of uh passion uh a sort of uh overindulgence i've got to have feeling that sort of feeling
because lust has obviously a meaning of sexuality about it, but it's like it's anything that you're obsessive about.
Free from that sort of obsessive need, free from desire, affection, thirst, fever, and craving for sensual pleasures.
So that's the first shackle, always wanting to find something pleasurable for the senses, to look at, to see, to hear, to taste, etc.
then there's uh the same thing he says craving for the body and this is referring to our own body and uh i can only presume this is you know being over solicitous with our bodies caring too much for our bodies being worried about our bodies always wanting to make it look beautiful stuff like that not accepting it as it is and then it says um the same thing
This obsessive desire and the desire and the affection and the thirst of people for form.
And this refers to other people's bodies.
Okay.
So that obviously can be a bit lustful.
But it's that, you know, it becomes a shackle, a shackle of something that ties you down.
And then, of course, there's eating as much as he likes until his belly is full and he dodges in the pleasures of sleeping, lolling and drowsing.
So these are, especially in this lockdown, this was really one of the dangers.
I think I mentioned in that very first opening talk that you have to give yourself something to do.
You have to have some sort of challenge.
or else you start eating too much and start just hanging about.
And it's a funny thing, but the more you hang about, the more you hang about because the body gets slothful and you've got to get up and give it exercise.
The lights have just gone off, thank you very much.
Ah, they've come back on.
I've got a problem with the lights.
So that's a big shackle.
Ties you down.
And then there are other practitioners who aspire to some order of gods.
In other words, they want everything they're doing is to be reborn in a happier realm.
And that's obviously, I mean, it's not an evil thing to desire, but obviously it's well short of our real goal, which is nirvana.
So these are the five shackles of the heart that has to be abandoned.
And of course, he says that any practitioner who has not abandoned these five wildernesses in the heart and severed these five shackles in the heart should come to growth, increase fulfillment in the Dharma.
That is impossible.
So there's our task.
You see, the five wildernesses, we'll repeat them at the end.
then of course he the whole thing is repeated for people who have abandoned these things so we don't have to read through that then uh towards the end uh he he also says that he must develop the basis of spiritual power um goodness power punya uh a real building up of of energy just like these um you know people who pump iron you know like they
energy just like these you know people who pump iron you know like they they want to get stronger and stronger and stronger and they're committed to winning the exhibitions and all that sort of stuff so it's that the exhibitions and all that sort of stuff so it's that sort of commitment and these are the ed power that we've actually done them in the past or the paths to the best translation path to success
Sometimes it's put us the path to power, but it's the path really to success.
If you want to succeed in anything, these four qualities are needed.
So the first one is a real desire, a real longing for Nibbana or for anything in your life.
Yeah.
You've got to really want it.
And then he develops the basis for spiritual success consisting in concentration due to energy.
So wanting something is not enough.
You've got to put your energy into it, your energy and determined striving.
And then he develops a spiritual power consisting of concentration due to the purity of the mind and determined striving.
So purity of the mind is not, this is for really anything really, to have good intentions.
we have good intentions of course that's very empowering you see so it's a case of giving ourselves uh really wholesome intentions for doing something and in this case to become liberated from suffering that's a good intention and then the final one is develops the spiritual power uh consisting in concentration investigation and determined striving so this investigation is really keeping that
ability to be you know to be able to be constructively critical about things you know to keep keep awake not to just do something
For instance, you might set off doing a task and then realize that, you know, if you keep doing this, you're going to exhaust yourself or it's not really working.
But you ignore that.
You keep striving.
And in the end, you end up with a failure.
So it's always this business of, you know, taking stock as to where we are at any one time.
And it's definitely true in the spiritual life.
You know, welcome to sail along, doing a bit of meditation, doing a bit of that.
And then we'll realize that, no, you've got to put a bit more energy to it.
Then sometimes you really go for a bit more energy and you realize you're putting too much energy.
And in fact, you're just over-efforting.
And that produces also a sense of not getting anywhere.
So that ability to have that critical faculty constantly with us, that ability to have that critical faculty constantly with us,
the fifth one he adds on to these four um this isn't part of the idipati is a sense of enthusiasm now it's translated enthusiasm but the word itself is a sort of exertion and it's often coupled with another word usaha which is means a strength or power so it really means he's really stressing this this real um complete full throttle energy to achieve
uh the goals right now as soon as you say that people you know we think oh i'm going to be a stream entrance i've got to get through the four attainments but um that would be the wrong thing that that is my that those are our aim the objective right the aim is to get there fully liberated to nirvana but the objective the present moment to moment objective is of course to establish that
that affectionate awareness at all times.
It doesn't have to always be affectionate.
It can be just a cool investigative awareness, but it's got to be there.
And that's the effort.
So at the end of the day, when you look back and you think, have I been mindful all day, you see?
So don't get upset.
There's no point in getting upset about it.
It's just a reflection that, yeah, I should have put more energy there.
I should have woken up.
I should have held myself, et cetera.
For instance, I had to go to the shops and
I went at the wrong time.
There was quite a long queue and I was standing in the queue there and I could feel this irritation coming.
Why don't we get on with it?
And unfortunately, there was a woman came out.
She looked at me and I think that sense of irritation was on my face, unfortunately, and I could see her turning away.
That's the way it is.
So now we've got these 15 factors, okay?
So then he gives the usual little metaphor.
Suppose there were a hen with eight, 10 or 12 eggs, which she had covered, incubated and nurtured properly.
Even though she did not wish, oh,
that my chicks might pierce through the shells with the points of their claws and beaks and hatch out safely, yet the chicks are capable of piercing their shells with the points of their claws and beaks and hatch out safely.
So too, a meditator who possesses the 15 factors including, which include also this real exertion,
is capable of breaking out, capable of enlightenment, capable of attaining the supreme security from bondage."
Okay?
So there's the present, there's the gift at the end of all this striving.
So if we go through that rather quickly, doubt in the teacher, in the Dharma and in the community, the Sangha, doubt in the training and being angry
or jealous with our companions.
And then to get over this craving for sensual pleasure, craving around our bodies, over solicitous around our bodies, craving for other people's bodies, overeating and sleeping, that's all one, and making an aspiration for a better life after death isn't quite what we should be doing.
If that happens, all well and good.
And then we have to get, so that's the five wildernesses, the five shackles, and then finally we have to develop this sense of zeal, of real desire, longing, with the energy, the purity of heart, the critical faculty,
and this all-powerful struggle, exertion to attain the goal.
And of course that, and always remind ourselves, we're not trying to attain any mental, we're not trying to attain any spiritual attainment, right?
We're trying to establish a moment-to-moment mindfulness.
This is the secret of success.
That's the Mahasi.
So at the end, of course, unlike the discourse we heard yesterday, the bhikkhus were satisfied and delighted in the Blessed One's words.
So I think he must have been happy about that.
So I can only hope that this helps you to become enthusiastic about your practice, that you will struggle.
The struggle continues.
La lotta continua.
um until that final day when you are completely liberated from all suffering and may it come sooner rather than later so we can do some city